bootleg head podcast
uh officially coveted for you y'all
caught that coronavirus filthy rich
you did yeah i'm like you know what
happened
no no you good i'm good i got two
negative tests
i respect it man but you know what
happened bro
remember when you was out in a z and i
was out nazi
and we was texting each other i was out
there you know
deep in some [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying she was doing djing and
oh yeah i was doing it i was running up
her back no exactly we
yeah everybody out there got that [ __ ]
yeah i was right there running up a bag
man shout out
man salute to arizona man but uh yo we
got filthy rich in the building
um you got a new album out
how many albums is this for you
officially oh
[ __ ] i don't know you don't know how
like what what number album this is
i mean we're past like 10 at least what
are we like 15
20. i dropped 12 in a year oh jesus
so are we are we north of i'm past 100
you're past 100 albums
for sure 100 projects for sure are all
those on the
dsps or just some of those like in like
on daph or like are they all
on spotify that's crazy
by the way shout out to uh brian sampson
for being louder [ __ ] in the background
yeah i've been passing them that's crazy
when do you remember the year that you
put your first project out
my first project that went like online
and everything was on 2008.
damn 12 years you don't have to wear the
mask
i don't have the rona bro i took two
tests i took
two if i get him when i leave here i got
double negatives
i'm gonna have empire invoice you all
right all right speaking of empire so i
listened to the album man
don't body your work um do you feel like
this is like
uh like the coronavirus everything has
been going on i feel like he
feels like he took a lot of time on this
project like
uh it felt real personal too it is
because of the title like it's kind of
like the sequel to fake love
and then real hate but um i feel like
the previous project hometown hero
before that was like that also
like i feel like you like like
vulnerable on this album i feel like i'm
on hometown heroes like that too i'm
just growing you know
you know we growing every day and going
through different things so
i mean me as an artist i've been just
like giving you me
like what i'm going through how i'm
feeling so
it's just that and then another thing
too you know we grow as artists every
day as
we gain new fan base every day too so
maybe more people might be more
in been tuning in more lately and just
probably just missed out on the past
stuff
um i i think it's dope that
independently what you built over the
last 12 years
is very impressive i'm sure that there
was opportunities for you to
you know go the major label route plenty
of times
i'm curious they want uh they want
everything
of course they do because i had a few
interviews whatever they was like they
wanted
whole catalog and
merch touring and all that you want to
cut of it all
everything i'm like well i didn't know
y'all in 2008 right
right right start from here on up right
like moving forward
yeah like we i can't do that i can't
take down what i already
built up and give it to you and then
just so happened i didn't do it and then
corona hit
i would have been asked out so that was
something that was recently them
i mean it's been a few times but yet the
last one was right before
can you tell us who it was with rock
nation so roc nation was was
was trying to do business with filthy
rich and they yeah i had um
i had a um meme set down on here and
that was something that
it looked like it would have been like
more of a 360 situation like they were
they were gonna want a piece of
everything you had going on
yeah including your old catalog
everything
yeah see that that doesn't make sense
like you said like that makes sense to
me
from here forward yeah from me having an
independent
mindset like i'm seeing money off
digital you know and royalties and sound
exchange and
ass cap and youtube or whatever so it's
like okay i gotta give y'all all of this
i don't even know y'all
like i don't know what you about to do
for me or not gonna do for me
yeah i'm saying so i'm taking a chance
as in believing in y'all
and hoping that y'all are going to do
something if y'all don't then i'm just i
don't pay y'all already
yeah and then you're like you're you're
left with less than you had before
100 who now obviously you know everyone
associates rock nation with hove like
who was it that initially worked like
was it like do you know if like jay-z
was aware of
like your what you got going on or cause
that you know they have their own anr's
and their own label people
and it was it was the rock nation
management
it wasn't the the label side got you but
they was willing to bring me
to a label and um it was um i mean it's
no like bad blood or anything of course
not no i mean look
people we you should always take every
meeting i'd say that to everybody
oh but his name is daniel okay actually
um solange baby dad
oh that's what's up yeah man that's
crazy because it's salute to salute to
daniel though for even just
believing in me want to sit down talk to
me like he came to my neighborhood like
he came to uh
i think um a release party album at
least party or
yeah i had going on he tapped in he
really came to the hood they was really
trying to
yeah and i had a video shoot out here in
inglewood he came through
so he really was rocking with me though
and i just i just talked to him today
actually that's dope
um but i want to talk about your like
like
because a lot of people who are watching
this might not be necessarily familiar
with who filthy rich is like obviously
you've been doing this for a long time
independently you're from oakland
but like i feel like there's something
about the bay area and independence
that go hand in hand it's been like that
forever like
um since i since they say master p been
out there you know i'm saying giving out
the game
all the other other guys been you know
with the independent route because i
guess it's just something that just like
grew from near to how i see it because
like everywhere i go anywhere else they
not really kept to it
true and i really hope to it like
they're more like
theo label this is this and all that so
it's like
and then like a lot of people when they
think of california they don't think of
oakland they always think of l.a
yeah so they're like yeah man about to
come to california i'm about to come
when you still didn't get a deal i'm
like man ain't no
labels out here nope only empire
probably the best thing going on right
in the bay area so i'm like you mean
you're going to la or something like
right right right it ain't the same this
is one of the biggest states of the
in the country nothing out there
so when it comes to your strategy like
i'm curious because i feel like
a lot of artists who are watching this
are probably real like most people
man brian sampson bro never ceases to
[ __ ] amaze me
anyway um i feel like a lot of artists
are obviously
if if presented with any record deal
would just take it
like i'm someone like to say they got a
record right yeah right and
it's kind of different when you getting
money already true
i'm saying so it's like a lot of these
like i was just talking on
a lot of these people it's like you're
not feeling a record man nobody
go check out another podcast that you
got something to do with it
or i mean that's not i mean that's not
necessarily true i mean i got homies
that they do not
take you to give somebody else if this
is how you can pay so a lot of artists
they're not going to
recommend another artist to get signed
knowing that this person can be bigger
than them can take from them they have
nothing to do with it
unless they got less they cosigned or
signed to them so
especially like if your artist has
coming in and you already
you know up to their level there are
situations but they're very few and far
between where are where there's some
genuine like yeah
that's some genuine people yeah yeah but
the ones i've met like
you know i mean it's the rap industry
this is the game so everybody looking
for a come up this guy might be
not popping into music but he got ties
and connections with a whole different
you know what you need so he's like okay
man you got to sign
me and i'll bring you over here or we
gotta we gotta sign our management you
gotta sign our label whatever
so would you suggest artists to
stay independent and just you know cause
like
i'm assuming at what point in time
because if you started in 08 i would say
like at what point in time were you
making like
real money off a rap um well it took a
minute
because it don't happen right away i was
just talking to my bro neff yesterday
he was telling me about um he had
checked his um dashboard at empire and
he had like 200
on it and i was like bro you only put
out one song yeah i'm saying so
i'm like it took a while like i used to
get my 50
to go pay my metro bill right happy with
it but the more i put out
i started noticing more money so that's
that's what the independent game came
from like okay man so i'm looking at it
like the
catalog keep moving yeah game like them
like like the cds
is the dope now you know what i'm saying
so the more i put out the more money i
get
so it took for me to go up there one day
not to empire to a different um company
while back and i was
they had a check for me for five g's wow
and somebody i was with was another
artist and he was like
man how he get that like and he's like
man he got catalog he's been dropping
he's been dropping so i've seen that i
just been on it
has that because i feel like it that
still holds true now in the streaming
era where like the more you drop the
more your spotify builds up
like you know what i'm saying like it i
mean
like my biggest itunes check like 75000
that's crazy
that's for a month yeah wow like once
once it generates like
you know it went from 10 20
50. that's crazy it was 30 at one point
then it goes up
and that's when you get that call from
ghazi and be like hey
let me get this big old bad girlfriend
you know what i'm saying i wanted to ask
you
about there's a line on the intro where
you say the ops you're on the same label
as the ops
now obviously you're on empire empire's
got
probably they distribute so many like
like 3 000 artists if i was about to say
so it's a lot yeah but i
took that at like what like what like
i i don't know who all your ops are
obviously yeah but i kind of took that
as like okay is this mozzie thing still
going on because i mean
both both you and mazzy are both marquee
artists at empire yeah
now at that time being i wasn't even
talking about him okay
yeah because it's a lot of people at
empire
um that i don't um fool with
okay yeah so so those holiday parties
are interesting
yeah yo i can't imagine
that'd be interesting the last one was
interesting um
i didn't really see anybody i'm sure out
of respect though for like the company
and for ghazi like it's
yeah yeah me and gazi talk i'm gonna
keep it real like like
like that situation is just like some
rap [ __ ] or whatever but uh
it never went further than that um
but ghazi has tried to play a big part
in it like to
get to the side and out of respect for
him you know a lot of things
have been you know i feel like you two
had had obviously some genuine love for
each other at a point in time in your
life
that was the whole point right that was
the whole point like i genuinely [ __ ]
with you
yeah a lot of people learned of mozzie
from you yeah yeah
so i genuinely [ __ ] with you and
apparently eugene really did
so well i mean you know look at the end
of the day i feel like it's like beating
a dead horse
yeah no no i mean you've talked about it
a lot but does that mean
i mean he has also not might not be as
vocal
like in interviews or whatever i don't
know if they ask
or say not to speak about it but um i
wasn't gonna speak about it and then i
heard the album and i was like i gotta
at least ask about that line
yeah but you know in his music he throw
shots so
that's why you might hear on the last
album the new album
yeah so that's where you might hear
something from me come from so it's like
okay a direct shot
or a sub direct shots direct shots in
the music so it's like okay what do i do
do i keep it going do i say something
it's obviously unfortunate i'm sure you
guys have tons of mutual friends mutual
acquaintances no we don't
oh you guys don't nah oh well a lot of
people picked they saw it
that's see and that sucks right because
it's like no i don't suck
it's just it does kind of suck it's cool
with me i don't care
i don't i swear to god i don't care like
it's almost like
it's funny to me at the end of the day
because it's like you guys wouldn't even
know each other
that's why i didn't introduce you to him
and then
you guys still pick the side and you
have nothing going on
damn so do you have you noticed fans
picking sides
um because that's where it gets kind of
because i remember when the jay-z nozbe
was going on back in the day when i was
a kid
i was on nasa's side and i was like [ __ ]
jay-z yeah
i don't really know if i noticed fans
right
cause you guys you guys definitely share
a lot of fans yeah yeah yeah we do
um i know the rappers i know it's the
rappers
rappers have picked sides that's fast as
in like you know
they like [ __ ] they feel like you're
gonna go [ __ ] with
this thing or they're gonna go [ __ ] with
me because of whatever
i feel like too with hip-hop it's like
did you notice people who you knew
before he knew them
choosing the mozzie side of course like
like can you say who
cause they're not relevant they're not
rep so not relevant rappers at least not
rather than him
fair enough yeah it might have been
relevant when i was [ __ ] with them
but they're not relevant now
okay that's fair um you
you and uh jim jones have a dope record
on this project
he's talking like you guys go back to a
decade now yeah
um has it like
you know you have you have records with
so many artists so many legends
but i feel like there's just something
about that pedigree
and your work ethic and what you've been
building that just
anybody who's paying attention has to
respect yeah like like even
like when the big artists come to the
bay they always grab me
bring me out like you know [ __ ] around
or whatever
um a lot of artists that um they were
talking before like before they blew up
we've worked before right no no we we're
talking about
you were telling me that you had an
opportunity to sign roddy rich back in
the day
how how many years ago was this because
rodney's been making music for
a while since he was a kid well this was
right before he took off
before he did whatever he did with nip
and meek and whatever like we had did
like
was this why he was still with bird yeah
okay
so you and bird almost connected
together on on riding a mutual friend
uh we came to the studio i think we did
like three records one night or whatever
and uh same thing with blueface too man
blueface we was in the lab
before he took off also out here like
like i'd be in tune to what's going on i
know i know bro
i've noticed yeah i i i pay attention to
it man
like you got to so why um why did you
end up not signing ronnie
um it wasn't just that i didn't i didn't
want to or nothing like that the
opportunity was brought to me
through a mutual friend or whatever we
worked and then [ __ ] after that i just
went back to the bay
and we laughed at that that's crazy we
stayed in contact
we still talk here in there me and face
still talk here in there too but
i mean i i i feel like it's better for
him
i mean i i mean he's having he's having
a great run right now
same thing with um blueface no with the
other guy i could have signed him too
mozzie i'm sure that that's
for some change yeah i mean you were to
think that that would have made sense
back then
i want to see everybody be a boss i want
to see everybody like i gave them
okay i think it's a plan like how to
become a boss like how to
run your company how to become a brand
i'm the blueprint to independent success
everybody would be like oh you could
have did you could do this like on like
like it was like
come up like i'm not no type of [ __ ]
like that like i'm not hurt i don't need
it you'd rather but a lot of people say
the game is to be sold not told you you
that's
and that's a whack thing to say so it's
like bro you shoulda did this you could
have did this and that and the way they
saying like in a bad way like
i'm like bro like i ain't trying to come
up off no [ __ ] like like
plus at the time uh he kept going to
jail
right he kept going to jail like like it
was some [ __ ] called like
flashes or some [ __ ] 10 night flashes he
kept going to jail kept going to jail
but while he was down i was keeping him
alive
yeah i'm saying like you could check an
old video i had with um
with rj and yg just went yg album at
first came
out mustard or whatever i had to i'm
sweating on wow yeah so
uh when he was down everybody was
hitting me hey man i need a verse
man he gonna be [ __ ] though but
it i don't i'm not looking at [ __ ]
that's come up like even with my artists
i just gave them both for rolex the
other day
you know what i'm saying i gave them
both rolex i just told them like i don't
want nothing i just want y'all to keep
working
that's fire man i wish somebody would
have did that for me when i was coming
up
do you ever uh see a a world in which
you and mazzy can have a conversation in
reconcile
and we could holler that's good looking
for show howler like it ain't
it ain't to the point like nothing has
happened to me nothing's happening it
felt like some
and we got some good rap music out of it
yeah yeah we did man look he was
snapping on your [ __ ] he was i mean like
you know look as long as it stays on
music i'm all for
for some rap beef but it has to stay on
music that's the problem
when you look at somebody like you and
someone like mozzie i remember when it
first happened
i was like [ __ ] someone's gonna die man
you said that i remember
these are the two [ __ ] that i
don't like i wouldn't want to see
anybody before either of them
you gotta understand too that was like
like
and then even from from a fan both i
mean when you both
like one of the dudes where you from
yeah i'm saying like
[ __ ] can't go sour you know what i'm
saying so
and at the end of that day too like
[ __ ] not finished i thought they liked
the way yeah i'm saying so it's like
okay i'm gonna give you a scenario um
when he made the song
the kill jeremy song he posted a picture
of
my house at the time being which it
wasn't my house at the time i remember
that yeah but
the next day the police was in front of
the house i remember
seeing that and being like [ __ ] here it
goes yeah so with that being said like
the once the police get involved i just
left it alone
because like if a rockwood went through
the window and hit him in the head and
he passed out there to try to come grab
me
right right right police involved i'm
done with it
that's why i didn't even respond to it
after that that's fair yeah
um do you and and roddy have any
unreleased music together yeah we do
what's that studio red room
you guys cut some records there that's
what we did the songs that and so are
you getting blue face
so you so how many understand blue face
zodian
zodian we did oh we did like three songs
too
i know zodia and zac though
it was something like that man that's
crazy shout out to blueface man
he's a he's a funny dude without the
roddy richie and blue face man they both
doing anything they putting on for the
west man
no shade man i love to see you know
people in this rap game win yo
the uh origins of the mozzie thing i had
somebody told me
stop me if i'm wrong or right but
somebody said it's because you you did a
project with someone he had a problem
with
no that's not the reason why i started
he did a project with somebody i had a
problem with
oh yes okay yeah it wasn't
it wasn't me so it wasn't you copy copy
someone asked me
somebody from you've heard that before
like i'm not the first person to bring
this
wrong way okay but i heard it the wrong
way okay okay
someone asked me from his way to do a
song with me
and i asked him about it and he told me
yeah it's good you could do it i can't
you know i'm saying but ain't no problem
but you can right so i feel like it the
respect could have been mutual same way
because you asked yeah like he was there
when the person asked me the song
yeah i didn't know him like is it like
so like show me the same courtesy i got
people from richmond san francisco
la whatever like if i hang with somebody
these my my boys in l.a right somebody
hear me from l.a to do it first i'm like
bro you know them
they're good right right right so that's
just that that's just kind of protocol
yeah like so
that's what it was but at the end of the
day the person they did the album with
in a [ __ ] up situation and and
all this [ __ ] happened over a dolphin
that's crazy over a crackhead
over there who was the artist he did
that messi moore
bessie martin okay that's what's up um
the mess though shout out to miles you
should have both of them
again i'm saying like i ain't mad i'm
not upset like
ain't no shade like do y'all think
whatever we don't we don't
it's 20 20 there's enough [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on i'm getting too much money bro
i'm still
japanese foreign still [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
i also feel like what's going on in the
world like it's like there's not like
like you know a lot of people should
probably put [ __ ] aside that ain't that
you know yeah like we don't have to talk
like they don't got to be it was a time
before i didn't know you i was straight
so i don't
it's almost like yo people don't got to
worry if you guys run into each other
i don't know at least on your end i
don't know oh that's fair i don't
i don't i can't say that because i don't
know the vibe when when it happens you
know what i'm saying
that's what you're saying as in music
wise bro i'm not tripping as in like
worrying about you
making songs or whatever but i don't
know you might be turnt up when you see
me or i might be thinking i don't know
um i've heard this before about you is
there
cities where you can't perform in
because of the police is vegas one of
them
oh yeah someone told me that like yeah
man i forget i was talking to somebody
about
something with you i think me and john
costa were talking and
i was like what about vegas he can't do
vegas metro on his head
yeah i think that they own my head it's
just what we rap about
well yeah plus i mean that's that's a
city where a lot of rappers can't
perform
so but was there anything that happened
out there it was just
your subject matter yeah i mean they
laid with me as a gang member but i'm
not a gamer
yeah that's they put that on a lot of
people now so and i can't perform them
in oakland either
you can't even perform your hometown how
long has that been
uh going on since 2008
oh wow so since you've been popping you
haven't been able to perform at home
i just did the road and loud but they
walked me you offstage
wow that's crazy man
king of oakland um i
you know you you you procraimed yourself
as the king of oakland
um a lot of people think
a lot of people who aren't from or who
aren't in tune rather
they kind of just group the bay together
right
it's like everyone thinks e40 is from
oakland
no he's from he's from vallejo i'm
saying a lot of people think that i'm
saying
people who don't know what the [ __ ]
going on like i told you when people
think of cali they think of l.a
exactly the bay even more so because
it's even more of a niche
but like um you have like independently
for oakland done so much
who's like the og oakland's probably too
short right
so when you say you're the king of
oakland do
do you get any any sort of blowback from
making that statement
um keep it real like if
that song i just said that i don't
i was just rapping like it's not even a
hook on the song i just said it and it
became like it
it ruffled a lot of feathers from
different artists but
bav gate years ago was saying he was the
king of oakland
yeah i heard that name in a minute yeah
a lot of people i'm sure yuctan said it
you know what i'm saying but at the end
of the day the line came out
and i i just named the song that and
and guess what you should feel that way
but short but short didn't say nothing
and big dogs ain't saying nothing and
t.i used to i mean called himself the
king of the south yeah
but he you know he went through with who
he went through with flipping ever but
like nobody from what i've heard
up there that's able to even say
anything that that's able to dispute
that has said anything you're saying and
say nothing
you know i got a lot of love for short i
got a lot of love for
all the og's from oakland that then did
what they did i look up to them you get
them saying because they did it before
me how can i not you know what i'm
saying especially because they're from
east oakland also
yeah yeah these are the guys that was
coming through my neighborhood these are
the guys i'm seeing when i'm selling
dope on the corner like
looking up to like who i wanted to be
like coming in to hang with my ogs for
my hood
so it's no shade to none of them by me
saying that but as in
musically wise and popping i mean who
who who doing what they're doing
consistently 100 albums
not even just 100 albums you're saying
that's crazy because even though that's
consistent 100.
i'm saying like for the past years since
i've been now i've been ideal since 2010
yeah i'm saying so that's 10 years
yeah and a lot of the oakland rappers
that
you know been doing anything it ain't
been consistently it's been hearing
their song here
video there feature here or whatever but
it's just you know you might not be as
hot as you was this year
but you stand warm because you're still
working and you might pop off again
but as long as you stay consistent
you're going to still keep keep yourself
in the groove
i wanted to ask you because i know you
you'll pull up in the city
and yo who need the features tap in
has anybody ever hit you because you
know there's a lot of struggle rappers
out there
making some horrible music has anybody
ever hit you in one of these cities
you're in where you were like
i'm good fam man somebody even the other
day for a thousand dollars for a future
well i'm saying like where you heard the
song and it was just bad and you were
like i can't even get home
for the bread as long as you ain't no
snitch i'll do this
even if some straight straight ass juice
whack ass [ __ ] before
it don't matter like have you ever had
to do the video for the whack ass [ __ ]
i got paid for it i stored the same
amount
for the verse as the video so you got to
do yo yo
run times two if you want the video yeah
because the video's more worked in the
verse
hell yeah so the first gonna take
10 15 minutes man video was a day's work
yeah so
i need the same thing that's what it is
so if you so if anybody what's the
feature what's the feature
10 000 for the feature another 10 for
the video
20 all in that's wild man you getting 20
a show
i was about to say good for you bro
yeah good for you um with this project
uh this yellow bz record i would when
you heard the hook
did you put the 50 cent thing together
nah you just told me about that okay
cause
i never i asked you because what
happened i just did the song
i was gonna without originally what i
was gonna do was
there was gonna be no hook on it i would
because i had to beat um tracked out
so i was just gonna make like the sample
louder for the hook
right and then i'm like man i started
looking at
the features on the album i'm like let
me get somebody
for texas because that's how i work like
i try to pay attention to where my
market is at
and i feed them yeah popping in texas
i'm popping in atlanta popping in l.a
let me
let me get these detroit let me get
these artists from each one of these
cities
and states on the tape so that's how i
kind of work
so if you pay attention to my music
that's how it is in those markets
like i'm big and so bam let me get let
me get mine so i got
yellow beezy and little jeremy little
jeremy popping out there in houston
right right busy in dallas
so i just sent it to him and um and bro
sent it back him and trap boy freddie
they facetimed me knocked it out like
you like it here sent it back
yeah cause i asked you i was like it was
a clear 50 50 melody and you're like
what
it's like yeah it's 20 he redid 21
questions see when i did the song
i didn't even pay attention to it my boy
royale he just sent me the beat
i did that and then i didn't put no hook
on it because i didn't know how i was
going to come on the hook because it was
kind of girly
how um how much are you having to adjust
your hustle for what's going on with the
kovitz like on the music side because
obviously
the live shows ain't what they used to
be like yeah i ain't really had no shows
since then i had like five shows
canceled when everything hit that's what
i'm saying like have you had to adjust
your business model or the way you're
getting bred through the music like has
there been anything that you've had to
switch up or anything that
you've had to do differently just been
doing the same thing dropping the music
and then doing a lot of videos
like the tape got 18 songs on it but i'm
about to drop the deluxe which would be
22
you know i just have 15 videos already
wow
is there going to be a questions video
oh wow did you shoot it
in dallas
[Music]
i just had a video yesterday with jack
boy uh
and then uh so i got the video with uh
rich cannon with um
blue bucks clan right shout out to them
mm-hmm
and then all the solo songs on their
videos already done um
obviously being somebody who's come from
a street background
i asked bernard this question and i
think he said he lost like two million
dollars what is the biggest
l you've ever taken in the streets in
the streets in the streets
because you know sometimes i mean i mean
shooting dice i shoot dice a lot
shoot and die well what's the biggest
hell you've taken uh
[ __ ] i'm probably like down like maybe
like 150 from
[Music]
from may to uh last month
damn you again oh i mean [ __ ] you being
i mean do you still do you still stay in
vegas
yeah house in vegas in the bay but no
i'm not talking about i'm not talking
from shooting dice
streets oh okay okay i'm on the streets
yeah in the street not in vegas
no no but you said about shooting dice
in the streets yeah you down
i'm saying you a gambling ass
[ __ ] bro we shoot we shoot we
shoot like
2 000 actually crazy
but [ __ ] you know this is ups and downs
you get that [ __ ] right back that should
not be man
what's the biggest l you've taken at a
casino
probably like a 50. damn yeah you feel
like [ __ ] walking out this casino man
stomach touching my back oh
that made me stop i had to i had to like
i had to leave it alone i was a sport
i hadn't been in there one day a sports
game 500 and it came out
and left 30. yeah yeah yeah it came out
you know it's like it's a high bro it
balance itself out
but when i first moved to vegas that's
all i used to do i go shopping
i go i go spend about ten thousand go
shopping go right to the table get the
money back
playing crap addicted to it yeah yeah so
i said damn now leave my bags yeah i
call him hey mr beasley you left your
bags here i had to go back at the
backside and got the money and went cash
down left and forgot about the
clothes and [ __ ] i bought but i used to
do that like every day
just so craps is your game of choice
because kind of vegas is boring
like if it ain't nothing going on so
it's like shopping studio
or gambling like it's not really too
much to do with strip clubs at nighttime
i don't really go
and the strip clubs there kind of fell
off yeah i don't really go out like that
to the clubs or whatever so i just go
gambling go shopping and going do you
remember uh were you
in vegas when strip hop was popping that
was a movie man
it was in there i remember marshawn came
in there turned up one day someone got
i remember someone got smoked in the
lobby man and that was it was a wrap
they put the plug on that
you mentioned it remember i don't know
if you remember but i had bought a
bentley
in l.a some years ago and it came back
stolen
oh really yeah and i went to jail for in
san francisco
so the guy he he worked it or worked her
own that spot
strip up yeah and he paid me back for
the car
wow strip hop was legendary man
yeah there ain't been nothing out like
that since out there i know like
mayweather spot is
it's cool but it's like it's like hit or
miss there i think mayweather's just
like open on the weekend
yeah i don't know man vegas is i think
everything's getting reshut down
i don't know man i've been moving man
i've been miami arizona la
the bay you name it man i've been on the
road man trying to move to it
you you're known to like do collab
projects with people who's somebody who
you haven't worked with on
like a full album that you would like to
do like a full like
tape with oh man ice work that's
opposite to a cd
fire shout out to detroit yeah supposed
to do a whole cd
uh that's the only thing that i had on
my schedule
i'm surprised you and burner never did a
full joint
that should be crazy for the bay do you
man burn don't [ __ ] with me like that
really you're real yeah oh you don't
[ __ ] me like that
obviously personally without the burner
but now burners are out there
not the chemistry he's not [ __ ] you
guys just never got like just oh we've
been around each other
you guys just never vibed no we vibe but
i don't know it's just some it's
something there that
you feel me that it ain't being being
talked about
but i mean yeah i mean i didn't i didn't
say this plenty of times you know
to to the inside people i just feel like
bernie don't [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
he's a good he's a great dude though
like he's a he's a good dude
he didn't do big shows of course he
feels he's never involved
um you know he didn't do a lot of um
stuff for the store or whatever cookies
and all that field just never involved
so i'll just be like i mean just like we
like i said you talk about the king oak
and stuff like we know who's popping and
what's going on
so if you're not supporting the hottest
person in the bay like
it got to be something do you do you
think because i feel like
i mean obviously taking that out aside
on
you know unbiased but do you feel like
for whatever reason like i feel like
byrne is another one of those guys like
you who's just been killing [ __ ] for a
long time
i just feel but i have no issue with you
you feel like he's slept on
in hip-hop because i feel like he
doesn't hit him i feel like sometimes he
just doesn't like
when people mention the bae like for
whatever reason
we all know him for weed and cookies but
like musically like he's been doing his
thing for so long and i feel like
sometimes i don't i don't i don't really
know because keep it real like
no disrespect i'm not really in tune to
the music so i don't really know um
if he's being slapped on or not like we
didn't dumb music before like i was on
the project with him and dolph yeah uh
he didn't done a song for me before in a
video or whatever but
that's as far as it went yeah i'm saying
so other than that
you know i didn't went to the store
before cookies or whatever i just left
the cookie store
right right where we got here so it's
not like it's not something like
yeah but i just i just feel like you
know it's just something in between like
i even talked to
people that's close to him right right
right why brother don't [ __ ] with me
like that you know what i'm saying so
that's fair yeah yeah hopefully you guys
you know yeah he's doing his thing
i i mean i could take the game from him
as in
the clothing the wii you know i saw
the last time i saw you you had your
your your strain with you
was like is it kill zone gelato five
nine yeah
um and you gave me some and i smoked and
it was fire um
but you still higher
getting into the weed game on the legal
side obviously
you know is where the world is going um
it's crazy that we still got people
locked up in the united states over weed
yeah well they probably locked up before
it was legal this [ __ ] is crazy right
now they're like
that's what i'm saying but now that it's
legal it should you know but but but i'm
curious like
have have you getting into that
legal side of the of the game is what's
different about it and like
have has it been challenging at all very
challenging because
like a lot of people do this [ __ ] like
black market i want to do it that way
like if i'm going to do it i want to do
it right so i've been working on trying
to get the licensing
and then like you know by them um making
it legal
now they want to tax it they want to
touch it they want to see where it's
being grown they want to test it so
you know for a black man like myself
they ain't just gonna just you know let
me in so i gotta
figure it out and wiggle my way i gotta
wiggle it you know
that's fair yeah have you is there like
any states or
areas that are easier to get your
license in
i mean i've noticed some of the homies
go to oklahoma
they want to see where it's being grown
at they want to they want to see where
it's been growing they want to test it
they want to weigh in right they want to
do all that so it ain't just about the
license there's more to it
there's a lot more to it yeah put it in
stores i don't just want it like it's
like me selling weight on the corner
like dude black market i want to have
mine right so when they come in here or
into the cookie store like
get the kills on they got the jars
everything professional you know
no i think it's dope though that you're
like you know diversifying man
especially you got to diversify now yeah
a lot of these this is me because
where i come from you know what i'm
saying they love to try to get me for
anything
right like they already like you said
they are labeled a lot of people label
you as a gang member a lot of these law
enforcement agencies
and that comes from i think the um
chief of police is from here in oakland
so it's like he
that's how they think they think gang
gang gang gang
what it was they wanted me to sit down
with them
and talk to them and film it like are
you crazy
i'm like i can't do that yeah of course
not i'm not i probably could have
somebody represent me
in your talk or whatever but me not to
say it like that but
you're if that leads with the way the
internet works now
listen that's all it takes listen one
day i was in the hood right
and it was a cop and he pulled up in the
truck playing my music
wow so he in the truck playing the music
right
so i'm like i'm about to record him so i
recorded it
but i didn't post it i deleted it and
then he jumped in my dm
it was like he was like hey boss this me
um the cop that was just playing the
music can you send me that video
and i showed everybody in the
neighborhood i didn't know how you could
read it but don't open it yeah
so i showed everybody in the
neighborhood and i and i deleted it
so because if i would have responded
back to that people would have been like
yo you talking to the guy
like if i responded back to that he
would have screenshot that and sent that
out
man come on man that had me on rap facts
and all type of stuff man
it would have been crazy oh man you know
what sucks though is like
you could have did that and that's okay
because you wouldn't do anything wrong
yeah but just how people would've took
you know but it's the internet they get
the hate or something to say
the internet's crazy bro they want to
say they say anything man they'll say
anything about you
do you feel like uh you know i was i was
uh
we had freddie gibbs on the podcast and
he had said something because there was
that you saw that video with gunna
on crime stoppers that's that's
different
and that's pretty he was telling so i
was going to ask you when you see
something like that
because something like you're talking
about it's not the same thing man
they're going to take it it's telling
off something
you spoke to the police me sitting down
and the police i don't know if they
understand that how it would look
but me sitting down like i'm talking to
you and talking to them and they filming
and putting out there
you know they're going to crop it in
memes and
and twist it yeah i'm saying so it's
just
do i do i lose my uh credibility
and it can affect your rap career
they'll be able to perform mm-hmm
and get money legally by the way so yeah
if i do this i can get paid to perform
but if i don't i have to just suck it up
and just say [ __ ] it
right right right money on my pocket i'm
saying so it's like
how do you win the same thing with the
legal system it's like
okay you go to jail you get put on ankle
monitor
or whatever you can't have a pistol on
you but you in the streets
you you you in the streets you've been
in the streets all your life so how do
you protect yourself yeah
so it's either go to jail or die which
one which one you're going through so
it's a poison yeah so it's like a little
situation really
yo i know you you dabble in the real
estate hustle no
no don't dabble in the real estate house
but you got houses everywhere that are
like that
houses you got houses yeah i don't got
real estate houses to where i flipping
okay so you don't get any of that guys
he told me to do that a long time ago
but
i just haven't i just been working my
way down different things eventually i
probably will you'll get there
yeah i've been doing the clothing the
dogs the weed
the uh modern company got my artist i'm
really trying to stop rapping
i'm saying soccer you said you have a
modeling company and a bay area
what kind of modeling company we talk
about here no females they do videos
hosting
you name them are they on back page
nothing like that by the way backpage is
retired
everything is legal man everything hey
technically
uh technically you could you could hang
out with someone listen them girls have
boyfriends husbands whatever i just came
together and grabbed
some models from the bay area and made a
company we did photo shoots we did
vlogs the new hustlers you got to get a
piece of their only fans
i don't know anything about that only
fans is legal no no
i don't know anything about that it's
crazy because now like like
like if you're a stripper and like
you're struggling right now
and you haven't made an only friend's
account like you're crazy
you're the only fan nah not me i'm
married i'm i'm straight but i'll be
saying [ __ ] rappers got only
fans accounts and [ __ ] i'm not ready
that [ __ ] i if i did boy
but i'm talking about even [ __ ]
i wouldn't be doing nothing i'll be
showing what the girls doing right
you know what i'm saying like i wouldn't
be on there like showing me you wouldn't
see me
of course not i mean you wouldn't see my
face or nothing but you'll see them
what they doing my only fans would go
crazy i'm telling you some [ __ ] to be
mad around here
like yo my wife was on filthy rich's
only fans
how much they get paid for that uh i i
think it all depends like
uh it's like a monthly thing we got a
friend named brian sampson who would
know he's subscribed to a bunch
might start me a filthy rich fan
hey that'd be f fire have just chicks
like send you [ __ ]
no no just gonna be six that i've dealt
with
so real women videos there you go i got
phones full of videos like i could dig
in the archives and get popping
and get popping right quick but they'll
probably try to sue me on like the girls
what you think it depends on what uh
state you're in if you filmed it
they watch and they listen no no but
listen listen if you filmed it on your
phone you own it
it's and i think in california it's a
one-party consent so i think you're good
oh yeah that's that's why all the porn
companies are out here that's like like
the kim kardashian tape ray j film that
he owned the footage i'm about to go big
what do you get for that oh he got a bag
yeah if you have anybody with any sort
of clout run it up bro
i'm about to go big run it i'm about to
go
big on the fans yeah why not man they're
gonna see me doing nothing yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] them ruin their life who cares
i'm just trying to get the bag you put
me on it i'm just playing with it
anyway yo man listen the album is out um
what's your favorite song i bro i [ __ ]
with the record with uh
with vezo that [ __ ] is hard and the big
six big five nine
yeah i listen i listened to the whole
album straight through uh yesterday and
and that record stuck out i like the jim
jones record like i told you
the intro was hard intro was fire
um keep it real that's songs oh the
intro
it uh i recorded i think on my birthday
because it's called
king oakland january 30th january 13th
king open one and two right
so that's from january yeah i just put
it on that was it
because there's a lot of you talk about
you know what's going on with the kovic
[ __ ] a lot on there too
like did you you and jim recorded that
joint in miami
nah i seen the gyms in the back okay
fair enough i just
came up with the idea i with the hook
the name of it from off what he said
whatever i just left miami no i just
shot two videos out there
um video for that song no i shot this
other song i got
four other songs for the um deluxe
that's the new way man go double up on
them boom
i got some new songs too i might do
another cd but
i might not that might be my last cd
real quick i'm curious like your last cd
ever
so you might retire i've been saying
that's what i want to do
so like guys you won't let me though i
was going to say how do you figure how
do you like like when do you know it's
time
um when you
when your interest isn't something else
think i'm saying like i said like
i got like other businesses right only
fans to starts
you know what i mean
for one i just don't want to sit back
and become a rapper that's just rapping
and uh you know no disrespect to any of
the older
rappers from oakland me i don't want to
do that right i want to
come in get my w again i'm saying yeah
get in and get out leave it at that and
then
this is this was something to open the
door for something else you know i'm
saying so that's how i look at it but
i've been doing a whole bunch of other
stuff that's been generating money so
you you talked about ghazi you guys
obviously have a very strong
relationship
empire's uh you know i think that
they've kind of changed the way a lot of
people think about
um how they release music um
what what is the like what what is
i asked mozzie the same thing like what
is it about ghazi what is it about
empire that
you know is is so good because i like
like you said like major labels been
knocking a lot of people yeah
um keep it real see if i'm not mistaken
i think um
like in 2012 i was just releasing
um music and then i think ozzy came
looking for me
it was like i have everybody but filthy
so i came over there
i think i released a series of simcity
money man one two three four
and then guys he was seeing
how my bag coming in and then like
well when you get a single we'll do
official official album
so i made to make a living record with
sue right so i
gave him that song and then that's when
i created the album around the single
so he was like okay let's do um
we're gonna do a budget for this thing
i'm like yeah and then uh i went half
so i came in and brought the money half
of what he wanted to put up right and
ever since then he always like
i respect how you move like you didn't
just come with your hand out
like and then that's how he like
introduced me to dolph because he was
like
the office is the same way like you can
of course remind me of each other
so and like anything i ask like if i
call ghazi or whatever like
it's done like it's it's i don't even
remember the time he's ever told me no
so and i know that he wants to see me
win i know that
yeah he's got he really is all about
pushing the bay man
to the forefront of music yeah he like
he uh he
like i was supposed to be anor over here
that was my next
yeah i mean you got the ear you could
have had roddy no no no no you got the
ears that's what i'm saying
actually do it now but just not on the
payroll right you know what i'm saying
like i
call like hey grabbed this person hey
hit this person up kind of like him this
type of stuff
but that was my next move after i was
done with the uh
done with the um music done rapping and
then uh
and then [ __ ] i just started building
over there
bringing artists over there bringing
artists over there so like whatever i do
they just respect it
that's fire man well yo go support the
album and um
yeah request questions
yeah man no questions y'all are busy our
single video about to come out
videos on the web um it's gonna be
though we did it like we was locked up
in jail too
and then the girls he was calling the
girls on the phone they was holding it
down
while he was in jail whatever i would be
wondering where [ __ ] find fake
jails where do you find a fake jail to
shoot a video
they got fake they just got fake jails
you can rent they got fake they got fake
private jail with with
the cages with the bars with the bed
all that they got yeah where they get
they have like they have it out here i'm
sure they got like oh they're definitely
different different rooms with different
like setups in them
that's what it is well yo filthy rich
appreciate you tapping in man appreciate
you
boom